c'est intéressant parce que avant on
parlait des rois de luxe dans lequel
vivait mais nous on vit mieux que les
rois de l'époque
c'est intéressant si on a une vie bien
mieux que louis xiv et tous les grand
empereur qui ont vécu avant nous
pourquoi
à cause de l'énergie à l'époque j'avais
des gens qu'il est ventilé l'été oui et
pas de réflexe quand vous regardez
comment ça s'est passé dans le monde au
départ y avait que l'énergie de l'homme
les faibles il mourrait tout de suite
hier avant-hier plus tôt il ya trois
jours je sais plus mardi
j'ai eu un malaise quelque chose n'était
pas bien mais si mon âge je sais pas si
quelque chose ne peut plus marcher
presque heureusement j'avais une voiture
170 chevaux de normes j'ai pu rentrer
chez moi
moi je n'ai même pas un centième de
cheval possible grâce à la voiture je
peux entrer à l'époque on n'avait que la
force humaine pour faire les choses et
les faibles pouvaient pas travailler et
il mourrait d'ailleurs rapidement et
petit à petit on a utilisé l'animal qui
apportait sa force animale
puis après on a inventé des nouvelles
chaude va utiliser les rivières faire
tourner des moulins à eau des moulins à
vent que l'on a inventé la vapeur la
machine à vapeur l'essence etc
les moteurs à combustion et au fur et à
mesure notre niveau de vie a augmenté
avec le niveau d'énergie disponibles
plus on a d'énergie plus de notre vie
devient inconfortable scène c'est une
conséquence ce qu'on a vu depuis
toujours et on a trouvé des nouvelles
technologies on a le nucléaire
maintenant c'est la technologie la plus
sophistiquée qui soit et pourtant cette
énergie n'est pas distribuée
équitablement dans le monde
il ya des pays comme beaucoup de pétrole
soit même pas quoi en faire tellement
usa l'on y en a qui ont rien il ya un
accord des moyens technologiques toi qui
les ont pas et s'il existait une source
d'énergie qui puisse aider l'ensemble de
la planète alors il s'est passé quelque
chose le 23 mars 1989 pour les personnes
un peu plus âgées ici que sont à la
salle qui était encore qui était reçu
suffisamment adulte il ya eu une grande
annonce qui a été faite à l'université
de l'utah aux états unis ou deux
chimiste électro chimiste un américain
et un britannique martin fleischman
estaing dépenses ont annoncé qu'ils
avaient réussi à faire une réaction
nucléaire dans un tube à essai alors je
veux d'abord que je vous explique un
petit peu ce que celle du clae r vous
connaissez tous le tableau périodique
maintenant donc je sais qu'il ya plus de
problème là-dessus mais je veux dire un
petit peu vous ça vous savez qu'on a des
réacteurs nucléaires dans le monde
entier en france d'un ans à 58 dans le
monde entier à peu près 400 il
fonctionne qui fonctionnent tous sur le
même principe qui s'appelle la fission
la fission c1 ou un gros noyau le noyau
d'uranium s'appelle le numéro 92 mais
bon c'est pas grave vous le cassé en
deux
hélas extraordinaire la masse des deux
morceaux est plus petite que la masse au
départ ce qui est extraordinaire parce
que normalement on devrait pas redorer
rien perdre
mais à une différence de masse et cette
différence de masse c'est grâce à la
théorie d'einstein qu'on comprend c'est
que la masse peut se transformer
l'énergie à une équation vous connaissez
tous le susurre cee galles mc carey 1e
c'est l'énergie
mc la masse ou la perte de masse et
cesser la vitesse de la lumière la
vitesse de la lumière c'est 300 mille
kilomètres à la seconde
donc s'il voulait lever au carré ça fait
beaucoup de zéros donc c'est énorme
c'est pour ça que l'énergie des
cliniques eu l'air est si importante
pour les pour certaines personnes c'est
qu'avec un petit peu d'uranium vous
faites beaucoup d'énergie
les pas besoin de grands des wagons de
charbon des deux pétroliers avec un
petit peu d'uranium vous y arrivez ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fission ça
existe depuis ça a été découvert en 1938
a été développée on a fait une bombe
atomique en premier on a fait des
réacteurs nucléaires ensuite ça c'est la
première méthode
la deuxième méthode ce qu'on appelle la
fusion la fusion de ces deux processus
inverse
vous prenez deux noyaux légers de
l'hydrogène voulait coller l'un contre
l'autre et à ce moment là vous fabriquez
de l'hélium qui est un gaz et l'énergie
la masse de l'hélium est plus petit que
les deux morceaux d'hydrogène qui la
verse mais là aussi vous avez perdu la
masse qui sera lui aussi en énergie
le problème est la fusion c'est que les
noyaux si vous avez tous appris ça que
le noyau est positif mais électrons sont
négatifs dans vous d'oublier des
électrons les deux noyaux est en positif
ils ont tendance à se reprocher aux
poussées comme les aimants vous avez
joué tout ça et des aimants vous savez
ce que c'est quand on essaie décoller on
n'y arrive pas tellement c'est fort
quand c'est très près alors pour y
arriver il ya quelqu'un qui a trouvé une
solution c'est le bon dieu ou son
remplaçant enfin c'est pas il a sous
traité peut-être et lui oui vous sous
traite beaucoup en ce moment donc il a
sous traité peut-être à quelqu'un et lui
il a trouvé la solution dans les étoiles
comme le soleil la pression qui a au
centre du soleil et la température est
tellement élevé que l'ags les noyaux
d'hydrogène arrive à s'approcher
suffisamment près pour fusionner le
centre du soleil de moi c'est la théorie
qu'il dit les modèles est à 15 millions
de degrés vous imaginez 15 millions de
degrés là c'est 20 degrés la pièce dont
15 millions est tous morts depuis
longtemps donc au centre du soleil à des
pressions gigantesque une température
très élevée
ça c'est la fusion thermonucléaire qui
se passe dans le soleil on a réussi à le
faire sur terre il n'y a pas de problème
ça a été fait dans les années et début
des années 50 ça s'appelle la bombe h
la bombe à hydrogène ou là pour arriver
à cette température on a utilisé une
astuce on a pris une première bombe
atomique
c'est le pétard le début qui comprime
l'hydrogène et qui fait exploser
l'ensemble ça a été magnifique ça fait
des bouts champignons et beaucoup de
radioactivité de choses comme ça mais ça
marche c'est non seulement c'est pas du
tout contrôlable donc ça fait une
explosion et c'est tout ce qu'on
voudrait c'est le contrôler
c'est pour ça que prêt d'ici à cadarache
il ya une suite à un projet qui
s'appelle projet iter qui est en
construction pour essayer de contrôler
ce mécanisme et comme là on n a pas la
pression du soleil n'a pas la pression
d'une bombe atomique avant on est obligé
de monter à 150 millions de degrés et
150 millions de degrés c'est quand même
assez chaud donc les parois en acier
qu'on peut avoir il ya aucune paroisse
qui tient le coup à 150 millions de
graisse impossible donc on laissait le
confiner avec des champs magnétiques etc
mais c'est très difficile ces deux
inventeurs ils ont eu l'idée
deux hauts lieux de seuil et de confiner
dans des énormes machines gigantesques
des cathédrales c'est pire qu'une
cathédrale en fait ils ont eu l'idée
d'introduire d'une manière douce de
l'hydrogène à l'intérieur d'un matériau
qui aiment l'hydrogène le palladium
adore l'hydrogène c'est vraiment un truc
une affinité très grande série à des
affinités entre les genres côté
chimiques un peu des fois et des gens au
premier coup d'oeil vous tombez amoureux
là c'est pareil l'hydrogène rentrer dans
le palladium tout seul pratiquement et
quand on a mis un peu plus en force à un
petit peu on arrive à les coincer entre
les atomes de palladium et commence à
fusionner et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
mais évidemment les terroristes quand
ils ont annoncé par une conférence de
presse à l'université de l'utah ce
qu'ils avaient obtenu tous les
théoriciens du monde entier ont dit
c'est pas possible il vous faut 150
millions de degrés vous avez pas sensé
un million de degrés est et à
température ambiante pas possible d
expérimentateurs ont fait des
expériences qui ont raté qui ont réussi
aux ratés et rapidement le sujet a été
balayée de la science officielle et
c'est devenu quasiment interdit d'y
travailler aussi bien en france que dans
de nombreux pays
néanmoins les gens continuent à
travailler et ça date de 26 ans
maintenant il ya une conférence à padoue
il ya quelques semaines sur la fusion
froide où il y avait quatre cent
quatre-vingt personnes qui étaient là
pour cette conférence quand même c'est
la plus grande conférence que les jamais
eu et on a commencé à approcher
maintenant non seulement à des as
d'explication théorie l'explication du
phénomène on a montré que
scientifiquement on avait vraiment
réussi à trouver de la chaleur on a
montré qu'on arrivait retrouver de
l'hélium ce qui veut dire que on a
montré que l'hydrogène pouvait se
transformer en hélium il ya quelque
chose qui produisait des l'hélium qui
était pas là avant et en même temps on
est en train de montrer d'un train de
passer un stade presque industrielle
parce que les ouates les kilowatts qu'il
faut des kilowatts et des kilowatts
enfin une maison c'est à peu près 1
kilowatt qu'il faudrait en permanence
pour la faire fonctionner donc c'est pas
avec une petite pile que ça y arrivera
donc maintenant on a commencé à
fabriquer des instruments des appareils
qui commence à fabriquer des kilowatts
on en est encore au stade de prototype
mais ça avance assez rapidement la
difficulté kaunas et qu' il ya très peu
de gens qui travaillent dessus parce que
le sujet est quasiment interdite le cnrs
ne se veulent pas qu'on travaille dessus
donc si vous voulez travailler sans
la clcv je ne sais pas comment on peut
faire sauf si vous êtes très riche
vous avez une grand mère riche quelqu'un
de riche à votre famille vous êtes bien
mais bon c'est très difficile et mais
petit à petit le projet le sujet avance
et les prototypes commence à sortir de
réacteur nucléaire de fusion froide qui
le produisent ni radioactivité ni
déchets nucléaires ils produisent que de
l'hélium l'hélium vous savez c'est ce
qu'on met dans les ballons qui s'envole
donc c'est pas méchant aussi voulu
avaler un peu ça fait une voix de
kadhafi c'est à peu près tout ça peut
faire donc c'est pas du tout dangereux
et c'est un produit très peu toute façon
parce que c'est au niveau nucléaire donc
les énergies sont énormes avec un tout
petit peu avec un g une expérience
récente avec un gramme de nick n 1 g
s'est pas beaucoup mais c'est même pas
un morceau de sucre 1 je sais pas
combien pèse un morceau de sucre vient
sais rien mais c'est moins que ça vous
devez le savoir ce que font la cuisine
ouais je sais pas trop et en tous les
cas graves de nickel pendant 32 jours
ils ont sorti trois kilowatts de chaleur
je veux dire bon ça va on pourra faire
marcher la voiture tesla avec un
générateur de sueurs froides bientôt et
1 g c mais c'est rien quoi un gramme
sait rien du tout donc on est en train
d'arriver un monde qui va réussir à
chaque une solution qui va changer
complètement la donne dans le monde un
peu comme il s'est passé avec internet
que personne n'a vu venir d'ailleurs je
suis désolé mais personne n'a vu que
l'internet avait arriver les mêmes les
gens de science fiction n'ont pas
imaginer une chose pareille et la fusion
froide c'est un peu ce qui se passe ça
se passe mais personne n'était au
courant
en fait si vous allez sur internet vous
êtes au courant mais on n'en parle
jamais et pourtant ça marche
les industriels sont intéressés des gens
du capital risque sont intéressés tout à
l'heure j'ai regardé un message c'était
un gars du capital-risque voulais me
contacter et justement pour travailler
là dessus parce que les gens savent que
ça va sortir bientôt ils veulent pas
rater le coche quand ça va sortir
qu'est ce qui va se passer lorsque sa
soeur mais on pourra faire des réacteurs
de petite dimension de moyens d'émotion
de grande dimension on pourra avoir des
unités qui fonctionne dans une maison
dans un village en afrique dans un
immeuble dans une usine dans les années
qui viennent on va y avoir un changement
énorme de paradigme sur l'énergie
ce qui va changer complètement la face
du monde ça va être le monde fonctionne
par cycles et le 6 juin fut inspirée par
les technologies nouvelles et ce nouveau
cycle va changer complètement la donne
et j'espère qu'avec ce cycle là enfin
c'est mon espoir moi je suis un
pacifiste premier un premier rang ont
entamé les débats en parle de 8 mais
tout ça mais moi je valorise plutôt les
cordier autres qui sont qui ont réussi à
faire des révolutions sans tuer personne
ça qui m'intéresse le plus
ces gens là qui veulent apporter la paix
sur la terre est une des sources de la
parlais tout à l'heure c'est des guerres
pour rapport pour avoir l'énergie et
peut-être que cette nouvelle technologie
permettra d'amener dans le monde un peu
plus de paix en aidant ces pays qui
n'ont pas de ressources énergétiques à
avoir des ressources d'un afrique ils
ont le téléphone portable
ils ont pas téléphone filaire prison pas
ils ont sauté l'étape et nous bat wil on
peut téléphoner film c'est trop
compliqué à mettre des films alors et
nous on était attendu plus longtemps
pour la voir le téléphone portable et
bien cette nouvelle révolution va
permettre de changer complètement la
face du monde et je l'espère d'être une
petite pierre dans l'établissement de la
paix sur la terre c'est mon rêve le
meilleur merci